we're here with Lucas Pope you have one
excellence in design excellence in
narrative and now the coveted Sheamus
McNally grand prize right here at the
IGF What's it feel like I feel like
passing out it's it's like can't even
thank you focus it's amazing it's a
dream come true absolutely Nathan valla
capybara games host of the IGF words I
want to say give you your your coveted
prize for best host of the ITA present
the whole time you know it's actually a
bunch more awards just like that that
are out there I will be winning all of
these awards tonight you're like
clutching it like it like a child like
just don't take it away from someone to
take it away you can tell by the way
address I was totally not expecting to
win so it's a huge honor just to be in
the same category as these are the games
like wearing huge fans of care about
space program is the game it is because
of the community because of you guys out
there get paid to do this we make video
games for a living it's amazing but gone
home isn't even a video game hell is a
win awards and I don't know they got
here somehow Thanks to everyone bought
the game really
love you like I love you personally so
much GDC awards are now over and we have
the winners of the game of the year it's
not enough for the last of us can all of
you on the count of three just give your
own acceptance speech from the heart
okay all right so one two three
thanks my
naughty Noah